Never snap to guides.
We want your mind, we
don't want your software.
If everybody loves
your work, you're
playing it much too safe.
You need some people
not liking it,
and then you're
probably onto something.
But a big part of
graphic design is
to get somebody to pick up your
book, to click on your site,
to walk across the street
and read the fine print.
Whoa.
If you've done your job as a
designer, people will do that.
In this class, I'll
be showing my work
and explaining why it
looks the way it does.
We'll look at color and
shape and texture and type.
What appears chaotic or random
is almost never the case.
I'm also going to bring
you a design workshop
that I give frequently
around the world,
giving assignments that
you can do at home.
The answer to everything
you're working on
is within the stuff you're
given from the client.
You're going to
have some reaction,
and then go with that.
I never set out to break rules.
I don't go to a
studio and say, "OK,
what rules can I break today?"
"How can I make
this hard to read?"
No, it's what am
I trying to solve?
What am I trying to say?
What am I feeling and
what does that look like?
There's so much slick, fine,
professional, forgettable
graphic design out there.
It's even more reason we need
a few rebels to make something
stand out.
Just the form sends a message.
Try not to get too literal.
I want to feel that
as much as we see it.
Trust your eye,
trust your intuition.
Every now and then, something
you weren't expecting
happens in the process.
You got to just trust your gut
and do what you feel is right,
and that's where the really
great works come from.
I'm David Carson, and
this is my MasterClass.